comme dans l'hexagone les laboratoires
privés pourront désormais eux aussi
réalisé les tests du coc vie de 19
depuis ce matin ils sont enfin prêts à
dépister
après moult péripéties des réactifs
bloqués à roissy par le transporteur
l'intervention d'un député puis du
ministère d outre-mer les premiers tests
ont pu être réalisés hier sur 35
collaborateurs volontaires une journée
d'essai primordial pour vérifier que les
méthodes de prélèvement et d'analysé
sont concluantes
c'est quand même un germe nouveau nous
avions des réactifs différents et nous
voulions et puis des précautions
particulières à respecter il fallait que
les gestes soient précis secure et que
les techniciennes les opérateurs les
différents opérateurs soient protégés
donc il y avait quand même une
appréhension et mais là la méthode en
elle-même que nous maîtrisons s'est très
bien déroulé cette chaîne de laboratoire
est accrédité par le ministère de la
santé pour réaliser ce dépistage
ils ont déjà une salle dédiée à la
biologie moléculaire entièrement équipé
deux extracteurs de termes aussi clairs
des hôtes spécifiques
il a fallu ajuster toutes les procédures
de traitement des prélèvements au delà
de la delà de la pratique de vraiment du
prélèvement nasopharyngé il ya tout un
environnement administratif à mettre en
oeuvre
enregistrement des dossiers étiquetage
des échantillons des contamination des
échantillons ensachage des échantillons
enfin donc sa nécessité de vérifier
en réel ce que ce qu'on avait mis sur le
papier et été confort n'était conforme
mais attention pour être testés il
faudra être muni d'une prescription
médicale
le laboratoire attend plus de précisions
de la part de la rs avec qui il
collabore déjà les personnels soignants
vous avez des gens qui sont
symptomatiques
vous avez des gens qui sont prêts
symptomatique et vous avez les gens qui
ont été en contact avec des gens
positifs
donc il ya déjà quand même si je veux
dire il pré sélection prioritaire ce qui
concerne les tice les tests avec une
capacité de 70 test par jour puis
bientôt 140 ce laboratoire d'analysés
médicales pourra appuyer le chum qui
attend encore son deuxième extracteur
les laborantins se disent même prêts à
organiser des drive test